[Applaudissements]
j'ai un peu plus de 30 ans et ça fait
quelques années maintenant que je
consacre mon temps à rencontrer des gens
qui ont à peu près trois fois mon âge
donc dans les 80 90 ans environ alors
non je travaille pas en maison de
retraite moi je fais de la vidéo et j'ai
décidé il ya quelques années de filmer
des vieilles et des vieux un peu partout
en france et dans le monde
mon but c'était de montrer comment
vieilli dans d'autres cultures c'est ce
qu'on a appelé une hall 10 et donc un
long voyage à leur encontre des dialysés
des vieux un peu partout sur la planète
donc on s'est fait tout un tas d'amis du
troisième âge dans tous les pays et en
rencontrant ses ordres de vieux je me
suis rendu compte d'une chose c'est
qu'on en entend beaucoup que les jeunes
veulent changer le monde
eh ben ils sont pas les seuls en fait en
donnant toute leur place aux vieux en
les mettant en puissance dans la société
ils peuvent contribuer à guérir cette
même société
alors est ce que j'irai jusqu'à dire que
les vieux peuvent être l'avenir du monde
et bah oui alors déjà juste une chose
j'avais déjà j'aime j'aime bien employer
les mots vieilles et les mots vieux vous
l'avez peut-être déjà remarqué parce que
je trouve qu'on tourne beaucoup autour
du pot avec les seniors les aînés les
anciens alors que on prend pas autant de
pincettes quand on parle des jeunes 1
c'est cool d'être jeune on a envie
d'être gel a priori dans cette salle si
si je vous dis ouah tu fais pas ton âge
tu fais dix ans de moins
vous serez flatter content mais si je
vous dis waouh
tous les rites que tu as je suis pas sûr
que vous gardez le sourire et c'est bien
normal parce que dans notre imaginaire
collectif
la vieillesse est une étape de la vie si
on peut appeler ça comme ça complètement
déprimante
quelle est la première chose à laquelle
vous pensez quand on vous dit les vieux
à des personnes qui seraient usées qui
serait triste un peu renfermé dans
l'eure c'était mieux avant et on a du
mal à imaginer qu'ils puissent sortir de
ce passé pour se projeter dans un avenir
auquel ils comprennent absolument rien
et pourtant les vieux ont ce pouvoir là
où parfois les jeunes ne sont ni écouté
ni entendu
j'ai découvert pendant notre know
tournage qu'il y à des communautés
il y à des pays des cultures ou être
vieille être vieux c'est synonyme de
fierté c'est synonyme d' audace et ça
peut même être synonyme d'avant gardisme
et de modernité
cissé samura elle devrait apparaître là
mais elle n'apparaît pas si c'est donc
c'est une grand mère sénégalaise voilà
merci si c est mon premier exemple de
grand mère qui change le monde ait les
mêmes arrière grand mère
donc elle habite dans le sud est du
sénégal dans un petit village qui
s'appelle bakayoko et dans sa région les
filles sont données en mariage très
jeune donc si c'est elle s'est mariée à
13 ans elle a eu son premier enfant
quand elle avait 14 ans et donc elle est
jamais allé à l'école elle a passé sa
vie à s'occuper de ses enfants et de ses
petits-enfants et la première fois que
cissé s'est rendu à l'école elle avait
60 ans elle s'est rendue à l'école parce
qu'elle avait un message à délivrer aux
jeunes filles
elle aura dit en langue peule
voilà vous continuerez d'aller à l'école
et si l'une d'entre vous est sur le
point d'être donnée en mariage à un
homme
village surtout vous venez me voir
ça fait quelques années que si c'est
avec ces autres copines grand maire du
village arrive à diminuer des pratiques
comme l'excision des petites filles les
mariages des jeunes filles et les
grossesses des adolescentes donc elles
veulent plus que lors que leur petite
fille ait la même vie qu'elle est en
fait elles sont les seules à pouvoir
faire changer les choses en tout cas
elles sont les mieux placés
déjà parce que dans cette région tout ce
qui touche à l'enfance à la maternité
c'est le sujet des grands-mères et donc
on peut pas parler d'excision on peut
pas parler d'éducation ou de grossesse
sans les impliquer mais surtout et basse
et grand mère
ce sont les maires des chefs de familles
de ceux qui décident ce sont elles qui
les ont élevés et donc le chef de
famille ne peut pas s'opposer à sa mère
à celle qui est la plus vieille de la
famille il lui doit respect
inconditionnel et quand elles ont
compris ça les vieilles quand elles ont
eu ce déclic et ben se sont fait passer
le mot de village en village et j'ai
pris conscience du rôle que jouent les
grands mères comme si c'est en
rencontrant une jeune fille qui avait
été sauvée d'un mariage un an plus tôt
qu'ils s'appellent fatoumata qui a 14
ans et et quand quand saison qui ont
voulu la donner en mariage
elle avait 13 ans et je lui ai demandé à
fatoumata pourquoi c'est ta grand mère
que tu es allé voir
elle m'a dit avec mes amis ce sont les
grands mères qui nous emmène sous
l'arbre qui nous raconte des contes qui
nous disent comment nos corps change
quand on grandit
comment on risque de tomber enceinte et
du coup comment on évite de tomber
enceinte donc on se sent plus à l'aise
avec nos amis et quand sa grand mère a
su qu'elle allait être donneur mariage
elle a réuni toutes les vieilles du
village et toutes ensemble d'un seul
bloc
elles sont allées chez les ondes pour
s'opposer à cette décision
la dot qui avait reçu les oncles a été
rendue et fatoumata pu continuer d'aller
à l'école elle veut devenir institutrice
donc ce mouvement sénégalais dont je
vous parle
ça s'appelle le grande mother project et
sa mise sur l'aura et l' influence des
grands mères pour faire changer les
mentalités dans une région où ben si
c'étaient les jeunes filles qui
s'opposaient à leur père ça pourrait
créer des brisures dans des déchirures
dans la société
alors vous allez me dire les enjeux dont
je vous parle de cette région poehl du
sénégal sont quand même à des années
lumière des enjeux qu'on peut avoir chez
nous et on peut se demander si dans
notre culture alors que les plus jeunes
peuvent prendre la parole ont le pouvoir
de d'être écoutés entendus parce que le
progrès peut aussi passer par les vieux
par les retraités
or déjà ce simple mot de retraités ça
laisse entendre quand même qu'ils sont
un petit peu passif tranquille en
retrait du monde et pourtant on se
rapprocher géographiquement de chez nous
eh ben on a encore rencontré des des
personnes âgées qui se mobilisent et
qu'ils se bougent pour les jeunes
générations
cette dame-là aux cheveux blancs c'est
anne elle a 70 ans
et quand elle a pris sa retraite quand
elle est devenue inactive elle a décidé
d'être mentor et d'aider des jeunes
issus de l'immigration a trouvé du
boulot
donc elle a rencontré sa fiat à sa fiat
à la petite trentaine a fui la guinée
conakry et quelques années et quand elle
est arrivée en belgique elle a cherché
du travail elle s'est inscrite à
l'office pour l'emploi est toujours les
mêmes réponses pas de travail parce que
pas d'équivalence de diplômes paraissait
d'expérience puis anne est devenu son
mentor et toutes les semaines elles se
sont retrouvés derrière leur petit écran
d'ordinateur là que vous voyez là et
elles ont répertorié ensemble les
organismes dans lesquels sa fiat un
voulait travailler voulait faire un
un stage elles ont déniché des contacts
rédiger des cv des lettres de
motivations parfois en français parfois
en néerlandais
et puis elles se sont préparées aux
entretiens d'embauché et en six mois sa
fiat a trouvé un stage qui lui a permis
de valider sa formation est de trouver
du boulot donc ce dispositif de
solidarité qui s'appelle duo fort au job
existe en france et en belgique
et ça ça utilise l'expérience des
retraités comme anne pour aider les
jeunes qui galèrent à trouver du travail
et ça marche puisque les résultats
montrent que après des milliers de duos
formés et bien les jeunes qui ont eu un
vieux mentor ont eu deux fois plus de
chances de trouver du travail
en fait les vieux comme anne les
retraités comme anne il y en a partout
autour de nous ça fait plusieurs mois
qu'on parcourt les routes de france avec
notre caméra et qu'on fait le même
constat
il ya les artisans retraités de l'outil
en main qui revalorise les métiers
manuels et qui donne confiance en nos
jeunes il ya micheline et ses copines
retraités qui tiennent bénévolement une
épicerie solidaire dans le sud ouest de
la france
et grâce à ce groupe de femmes et ben
des gens qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
moyens peuvent manger correctement il y
à fernand 81 ans et sa femme geneviève
qui accueille bénévolement enfin
gratuitement chez gino un jeune qui
vient du kurdistan de l'irak
donc on en a rencontré des centaines on
en a filmé des dizaines des exemples qui
montrent comment les vieux peuvent
guérir la société alors bien sûr j'ai
pas envie non plus d'idéaliser le
tableau 1
un vieux c'est une personne comme une
autre et il ya au moins autant de de
vieux cons que deux personnes âgées très
sympathique il ya autant de deux
vieilles vieux ronchon que de grands
airs gâteau et il suffit pas d'être âgé
pour détenir une vérité absolue
ils sont d'ailleurs tout sauf ça gèle
les vieux qu'on a rencontrés mais voilà
en en fait sans les sens les jeunes et
ben sans les vieux les jeunes ne ferait
pas grand chose et vice versa 100 à sa
fiat aurait pas trouvé de boulot sans sa
fille at her and aurait pas vraiment
donner un sens à sa retraite sans
fernand et geneviève et ben chine aurait
pas de toit et sans ce jeune kurde
ce couple de retraités auraient
peut-être un quotidien un peu plus
triste une grande maison un peu vide
donc c'est la combinaison des deux qui
fonctionne et aujourd'hui quand on parle
d'avenir
on mise énormément sur la jeunesse et
elle se bouge le mouvement des jeunes
pour le climat
par exemple réuni des millions 13
millions de personnes à travers le monde
parmi lesquels une majorité de
collégiens d'étudiants de lycéens
mais si on implique les vieilles
personnes et qu'on leur donne les clés
pour comprendre ses enjeux
alors il suffit d'un doute il suffit
d'une prise de conscience et l' envie
d'agir pour ses petits enfants peut
devenir un moteur puissant pour
amplifier le mouvement
parce qu'il faut pas oublier qu'il ya
bien des vieux qui ont déjà passé toute
leur vie à mener des luttes qu'on estime
aujourd'hui réservé aux jeunes la lutte
contre les discriminations le racisme le
sexisme l'homophobie
il faut il faut continuer à aller à les
inclure dans ses luttes et les embarquer
dans les nouvelles parce que les vieux
font pas partie du passé ils sont là
aujourd'hui et ils peuvent faire du
futur leur bataille du présent et ce qui
est formidable c'est que ce futur pour
lequel ils vont s'engager et ben il le
connaîtront peut-être et probablement
jamais je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]